aujourd'hui le gouvernement grec pour
digne à la hausse non
1947 au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale les outils de travail détruit
entraîne des pénuries et une flambée des
prix alors les français manifestent
contre la vie chère
l'offensive est déclenché il faut
substituer à la psychose martel de la
hausse une sorte d'émulation pour la
baisse et tous les secteurs de
l'économie française suivront le mot
d'ordre est de 5% le cycle infernal
wattel privé une baisse des prix imposés
par le gouvernement de léon blum qui
porte ses fruits car les commerces
jouent vraiment le jeu certains
commerçants convaincu de l'efficacité du
geste ont même été plus loin c'est à 10%
en certains endroits que la baisse a été
portée
ce contrôle des prix est mené sans
relâche pas question que les commerçants
profitent de cette vague inflationniste
pour s'en mettre plein les poches ce
gouvernement a lancé l'offensive dès
éthiques
suivant les instructions reçues et sous
l'oeil inquisiteur du contrôle
économique les commerçants de détail de
l'alimentation du mandataire des halles
aux marchands le cresson droite affichés
côte à côte prix d'achat et prix de
vente indiquant ainsi la marge de leurs
bénéfices après les étiquettes prix
d'achat prix de vente un nouveau magasin
est né le magasin témoins ici les prix
servent de référence aux clients et la
création des magasins témoins ont
provoqué une baisse sensible sur la
charcuterie et par incidence sur la
viande en général
appuyant l'effort du gouvernement voici
que le public se met de la partie sur
certains marchés les consommateurs
transformer en contrôleur bénévoles aux
lèvres pour les afficher les prix les
plus bas et la grèce du bon marchand
réflexe aimait bien les autres
commerçants se met au diapason pour
n'être pas borie côté des commerçants
dénoncé boycotter des prix imposés par
l'état un état qui va même jusqu'à
vendre directement de la viande aux
français pour s'assurer du juste prix le
gouvernement a pris l'initiative
d'ouvrir sur les trottoirs des
inventaires volant pour mettre en vente
la viande achetée prioritairement par
ses soins l'expérience de début dit aux
offensives du gouvernement contre les
profiteurs et pour le bifteck moins cher
est commencée et la police du bifteck
manche elle n'hésite pas à intervenir
chez les détaillants les deux messieurs
de la police économique repose avec
gentillesse et sous peine de saisie une
rectification des répits kate ont pris
du barème un contrôle assidu des prix
qui a participé entre autres à la
victoire des français contre l'inflation
folle des années 40
[Musique]